hi i think we're on here all right
uh today i want to talk i want to show
you a little bit how i um
study
on my ipad which is where i spend most
of my time now
uh as you know i use link
so i make no bones about it i use link
that's what i like to do that's how i
like to study of course i'm connected
every so often i get someone on my
youtube channel
who says yeah you always talk about link
or why do you knock other people's
products or stuff like that so
i like link
and
i like doing these uh videos i like to
encourage people to learn i also want to
encourage people to use link obviously
uh if people find value in what i'm
doing fine if they don't then of course
they needn't
listen to me
so that's fine
um yeah so here is
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
project
my uh
you know ipad screen onto my
screen a screen that i can share when i
do that then i lose the sound all right
so first of all here is of course a
typical page so i'll just show it this
way first let's get out of here
and uh so these are my franz van gaal
this is my course sponsored cut where i
have had various podcasts transcribed
again i don't know what i can show you
on the screen but a new thing we're
doing this is a beta version we have the
ability now
to basically create a playlist of the
course so that i'll show you hopefully i
can show you on the screen this is in
beta no one has it yet i have it so that
you can click and then you can listen to
all of the lessons that are in that
course which for something like franz
van kette which where each interview is
25 minutes long that's not so important
but if you have
the many stories then it's really good
to have a four-minute mini story
followed by the next and the next and
the next in a playlist so that's
something that will come up but
as you can see here i have a number of
these and i have been working on the one
from december
get my glasses on
december the 9th we're approaching the
end of our 90-day challenge and i'm
trying to crank it up but it's difficult
for me because as i've said before i'm
caught between
the easy content that i've been over so
many times and the difficult content
that is really too difficult now
this uh particular interview from
december the 9th which i had transcribed
is an interview with a political leader
in lebanon so it's very interesting
because he talks about the different
parties in lebanon and
israel and syria and so forth
and but what's very nice is that his
voice is pleasant to listen to
that's very important even though i
don't understand most of what he's
saying
i catch some words plus his voice is
pleasant to listen to the sound quality
is good
he may have some regional
pronunciation i'm sure any of you arab
speakers there people are always quick
to point out don't listen to him don't
listen to her this is not good that's
not good it doesn't matter to me i'm
learning words uh when i learn
portuguese whether i listen to european
portuguese or brazilian portuguese it
didn't really matter i'm learning words
i have to be able to understand
all those people
many of you dealing with accents don't
don't want to learn spanish or mexican
or colombian or australian or scottish
really you should get used to them all
and if you're reading it's the words
that you're requiring the vocabulary and
you should expose yourself to a variety
of accents so it's possible that the
person here has some kind of a lebanese
accent i don't know
for people who understand arabic i will
let you
[Music]
listen to
[Music]
so far i'm following after that i start
to lose more and more of it
uh
so he has a pleasant voice has a
pleasant it's not too fast he may have a
regional accent it's not something that
i can tell
and uh so now
let me see if i can set hook this up to
my computer
and whenever i do this it wants to
import photos and videos and stuff like
that which is a bit of a nuisance
but i go down to my quicktime player
and then i go to file
new movie recording
and then it says operation could not be
completed hit okay
why boy i was doing it earlier
let us try again quicktime player file
new movie recording
here we go okay
so i am now
going to
share the screen
let's see again this is uh we hope all
this stuff works
screen share
bomb
start screen share
and present to everyone
so hopefully
now
mute no okay so this should be working
so you are now looking at
the page
of uh and so
this is now on my ipad we're seeing ipad
so as you'll see here i have
gone through
um
can i move my cursor uh you know this is
the first page so here
you know while i'm struggling with uh
difficult um content in arabic
um and there are spots where the
transcriber didn't transcribe and for
whatever reason these were all jumbled
together but
nevertheless by and large page one lots
of white words
okay
oh i forget that i can't change it on
the screen so
so if we go to page two
you see there's more yellow words but
still lots of white
so i am you know even though i have
trouble understanding it i'm encouraged
by the fact that there's more and more
white on the screen obviously if i go to
a page that i haven't been to yet
there's lots of blue so here typically
what i do
is i would go you know i done i know i
done i know
uh
[Music]
reference all right
did we get that yeah that worked mine's
okay
so i go through and i will
convert all the blue words to yellow
uh
and i i i will sometimes find a um
a yellow word
that i know
i think for example erupt is a
connection or linking so by this time i
know that word i'll move that to white
so in the same at the same time and
sometimes if i see uh you know
tashkeel
here
by now i know that form the government
so tashkeel
i might that phrase i might just say
yeah i don't need that phrase anymore
and tashkeel to form formation maybe i
know that now so
i'm moving these to white
but
i may move them back to yellow at some
point
uh
because i forget them or whatever so i
go through this
and uh i've listened to the first part
in fact i've listened to the whole thing
quite a few times
and you know i'll plow through it for a
while because it's tiring
converting words
then i'll listen to the whole thing and
then i go forward again by this time i
have a bit of momentum to the new part
that i'm looking at um if i want to
uh now here there's a you know four
there's a
413 links if we look up here i should be
doing this on the screen here wait
there's 413 links in this text that's
413 words that i'm trying to learn
there are still 88 new words for me
um yeah it's a bit confusing for me
because i point to it on the screen but
i have to do the activity on the ipad
uh
so
uh oh and one thing i wanted to show you
if i quit
and i go to the top
of this course
oh play course audio they added a new
thing
okay
so the other day in the beta they had
this little eye guy upper play course
audio and i said that no one's going to
notice no one's going to find that so
now they've added a little thing here
this may not be how it shows up in the
end because we're still in beta but this
would give you an opportunity in any
course
to play the course audio which for the
false fan cut is not such a big deal but
if i go to who is she for example
and which is 26 stories i mean i'm very
excited about that now because i can go
in
and play the course audio
uh
and in the uh in the who is she lessons
of course you'll see that there are zero
blue words
and in many cases very few yellow words
very few well and then as i
progress uh you know 7 8 5 13 18
obviously in the later stories there are
more and more yellow words words that i
have previously saved and don't yet know
but if i look at the story here like if
we just pick this for example
and i open that
so it's almost all white words so
whenever i get discouraged that i'm not
progressing quickly then i go back to an
earlier lesson and realize that really i
have learned a lot of words
um i'm just wondering what else i should
show you on the uh
because since we got the ipad up here so
of course i can look at
courses first of all i can set the um
i i was going to remember to look at the
screen here
so yeah there's a variety of settings
you should look at
obviously i look at my daily link i've
been doing a lot of linking in arabic
um
well you know
courses i can set it to lessons instead
of courses
you know
i go to lessons i look at the last
lesson that i was
as well you'll remember i showed you
part five of who is she
and then
falls.get
um
and then you know i can go to the
library my lessons vocabulary playlist
and of course if i go to the playlist
um
and the playlist
tells me that it's a this is a hundred
of 108 items don't yet know what that
means is still in beta but we are now
allowing people to add more and more
lessons to their list
uh in some way that i'm not entirely yet
sure of but it's in beta oh yeah so you
can at the bottom of your playlist now
you are able to
add more items to your playlist
so that was one of the problems that
people had identified
um let's see what else do i do on here
uh let us go back to my lessons
um
yeah if i go back let's say courses
uh
go to who is she
so often what i do now since the let's
say the back half of who is she i still
got a lot of words that i need to learn
so i'll open up a lesson
and before
i go through the lesson again
i'll focus just on the words that i
don't know or that i don't feel
comfortable with
so i can either go through the find them
on the text
or i can click
up here
and
go through them 19 of them
or i can read this page and then i'll
have the
various activities
related to that particular page
i don't know trust confidence anyway i
got a lot of them wrong uh and i go
through them
and uh
again as i've said and i do the
dictation which isn't gonna work
because there's no sound while this is
plugged in
uh i go through these
not with the intention of getting them
right
i go through these
um
as additional exposure
so quit all right
um i can go back to this i will now exit
this and
see what questions there are so stop
and there i am
and now i will have to unplug the ipad
so that i can get to your questions
uh let's see here
it's a bit confusing here because i'm
kind of doing all kinds of different
things
kind of like
all right turn off the audio
and uh okay
all right
so
okay now hi steve hello i like thinking
why the price hike
because we have been you know we still
do have to cover our costs
and we felt that we would grandfather
the costs for people who were already in
the program give people a break on the
six months and 12 months deals but we
would try to get a little more money for
the
um monthly besides which the more and
more of our sign ups are from
uh mobile and ios charges 30 for every
sign up
so that also eats into our revenue
uh thank you for all the tips stephen
i'm really struggling in french learning
especially in writing well yeah i mean
you got to read a lot listen a lot that
gets the language in you
and then you'll find that your writing
will gradually improve but you also have
to write a lot and uh i mean writing is
like speaking really if you can speak
well you'll be able to write wrong in
order to be able to speak well you have
to get the language in you through lots
of reading and listening
okay so ten dollars a month was a
reasonable price but twelve is not okay
um you know that's what it is we have
made that decision uh
we are not changing it
uh
junior steve have you thought about
users extending their streak by
listening to some amount of audio
instead of adding 13 new links
through users extending their streak by
listening to some amount of audio
instead of having 13 holidays
justin that's a very good suggestion and
i think
one of the things i want to do
when i go back to vancouver on thursday
sit down and see how we can feature
listening more i think listening is is
the key activity that's why the playlist
drives a lot of my learning i listen i
don't understand
then i go
and look up words and phrases but it's
the listening that drives it i think
that's a very good point thank you
i'm running belarus i'm surprised
there's so much content on link that's
great yes we have a
few i think very keen members who are
from belarus
and so that's great um
no it's not going to be just about
arabic
hi do you recommend assimil to learn
arabic
it's a source
uh it's a source of content
um
the lessons
certainly the first lessons and quite a
lot of them are spoken very slowly which
is kind of good
uh i found the content itself quite
uninteresting artificial trying to be
cute sometimes
uh it's not one that i listen to a lot
but i did upload it onto link and i had
the lessons transcribed so that i could
study them on link but
in a way the vocabulary there is of less
interest of the subject matters of less
interest so i have not been overwhelmed
by asinil for arabic
about 10 years ago i found out that you
can buy keyboard stickers in different
languages you can buy a sticker with
four different languages
yeah i mean i'm not so keen on keyboard
stickers
i would rather uh simply
there's so many at least on my mac
there's so many different keyboards
for so many different languages i can
show you how many languages i am able to
type without stickers i tend to go that
way
meow pao i'm arabic and i understand
everything but my god this is going to
be difficult good luck thank you ma'am
paul but it's interesting
steve is more tech savvy than my mom
okay do you take seriously adding the
right word definition if there's a verb
and a noun definition are you trying to
add to your link
i don't fully understand the question
but um
when i look up the dictionary definition
i'm looking for something that's going
to help me get through the text so i'll
grab something if i think it's
not quite right like you'll see other
people have saved definitions that are
not very good sometimes i remove them
but sometimes i put three or four
definitions in there because the next
person may be
may be interested in one or other of the
other definitions
um i try to read in spanish every day
good i'm about to start
russian soon should i go straight into
many stores to get a lot of exposure or
will be better start with three to six
months of babel a bit intimidated with
slavic languages sophia i would get
myself first of all we do have
a grammar for russia if you go to your
profile you'll see the grammar
it's just an overview it's something
that you can go to
many many many many times but if you are
new to russian it will be overwhelming
i would recommend that you get yourself
a little starter book
teach yourself something i just find it
it's reassuring to have a book
and it introduces lessons and it
provides some explanation which we
promptly forget or we don't even
understand initially some of these
explanations
uh but it's part of the sort of
gradually getting into the language so i
would certainly i would start with many
stories i started with many stories in
persian and arabic where i was also
dealing with the problem of a different
script
so
i would certainly do the many stories
but if you have other sources
by all means you know go for it see what
you like
yeah first learn the alphabet but that's
not so difficult and the more you read
and listen the easier
the alphabet becomes
uh but yeah the uh
the uh
question of the grammar and stuff it's
going to take you a long time to get
used to it you know language learning is
is a long distance event
it's not a sprint
and it takes our brain a long time to
get used to first of all with the cases
i think fairly soon we start to
understand the idea why the instrumental
is the instrumental why the you know
direct object or whatever the dative
whatever they call it why why it is
there we understand that although there
are some reasons in slavic languages
having to do with numbers
and negatives which are difficult to
understand
you know but nevertheless we understand
possessive we understand these things
however trying to
remember the endings
uh when we produce the language is very
very very difficult that's why i think
it's best to focus on comprehension
first because comprehension you can
still get it wrong by not knowing the
case
but it it
there's so many words typically in all
languages the words are redundant you
can figure out the meaning in most cases
and if you are in doubt if you're
reading uh
online you can look up
that particular
noun or adjective to see which case it
is
still you're not always sure for a long
time when i was doing a
russian i would save
you know different nouns and adjectives
for what i thought the case was often
getting it wrong
and then when i review these in the
vocabulary section i see by now i'm a
little smarter that that one shouldn't
be there so i remove the tag so those
are some of the things that you can do
but cases is going to take a while
i'm in the sixth month now there are
some great books like penguin russian
course where you can learn about every
case for me it is easy because my
language also has cases yeah the problem
is not just understanding why they have
cases the problem is
trying to remember the endings
across three genders okay so it's don't
be in a great big hurry to master them
you won't at least in my experience
uh at the present time we don't have the
tutoring service on the mobile version
um
but uh you know
all of these things i would like to see
them the
development groups small group have
their tech priorities and what they're
working at
if you want to see features talk it up
on the forum if there's a lot of people
who feel that this is a priority then we
can get there i know it is in the works
it's something we want to get to
uh you know tutor via the mobile
do you think for someone who's trying to
sound as native as possible
that's a good idea for them to study
japanese pitch accent
i am
i would say that i speak japanese well
and that i have good pronunciation in
japanese i
don't understand what pitch is about
i've never worried about pitch i think
it's an unnecessary complication
ah i'm very good at how to learn english
listen and read yes sir
gregory ajtt should i learn to write the
kanji from memory for each word or is
the ability to recognize the kanji
enough when learning japanese
when i learned kanji
which i learned for chinese i wrote and
i found the writing
helped me learn them however today there
are many more ways of learning the
characters you're not going to write
them very often by hand
if you can recognize them then you'll be
able eventually to use your computer
because you can type in the pin or the
hiragana
and you see three or four characters and
you know which one it is so being able
to write by hand is a less important
skill than it was 50 years ago
the
question is can you learn the characters
without actually writing them out i
don't know the answer because when i
wrote when i learned characters i had to
write them up
how do i import material into link on
the app
okay
let me go i i don't do that but i know
you can so let me just have a look i'm
going to share my screen
then i have to unplug this
um
okay
um
you know what i'm going to make a note
of that and any specific questions
uh i'm gonna when i go because when i go
in to show you where to do it
um
then i lose all the questions here
so import
but but the quick answer is i believe
you can but i don't
uh i hate learning uh grammar rules that
avoid studying as much as possible i
prefer math and input i heard it gets
too difficult
do you agree that writing is more
difficult than reading
yes writing is the most difficult but in
a way speaking is more difficult because
you have to speak immediately you have
to find the word immediately
writing you can look things up so to
that extent it's easier but writing is
more work you have to have the patience
to write you have to think of something
to write about speaking you just speak
so
but uh
yeah reading is probably the easiest
assalamualaikum thank you
uh
composer what new languages are we gonna
link this year it will depend on what we
get offered to us i hear there's some
hungarian in the works
um
there's some georgian someone is working
on it depends what languages people are
prepared to
create content for
uh i just used welcome to trans
byzantine history in greek and uploaded
to link i'm probably a2b1 i'm very
interested do you recommend my jump to
such an advanced level
uh this is gus evening you know
unfortunately we don't have a lot of
intermediate content i think interest is
a big factor uh you're going to find it
very difficult because presumably a lot
of names
you know personal names place knees i
mean i did
that with my greek i found this podcast
on the building of the parthenon
which i actually paid someone to
transcribe i didn't know that
there were these other less expensive
options
um
so uh
you know go for it you're gonna struggle
and then go back to easier stuff and
then struggle this is it's that constant
back and forth
make the mobile able to edit lessons
okay
uh i agree with you lazarus
we should make it possible to edit
edit lessons on the app
although i mean you can get
to though
okay many lessons have mistakes i mean
until we actually make it
uh okay so all these issues mistakes and
lessons
at the very least let us know
yes and these typically are reported on
the forum
uh
and maybe that's not the ideal place to
do it but
that's one way to do it
uh we give people an editor's pencil so
they go in and edit
lessons um
again i don't know how quickly we're
going to be able to edit it on the app
but
i appreciate people who make comment
content i've made a note of it i'm going
to be discussing it with our people and
see what we can do in the meanwhile you
could also send me an email steve at
link and we can follow up with you
yes me is good i've used smile for two
languages and i thought it was
exhausting i didn't know
yeah i mean i think the russian asimil
is one of the better ones because the
content is quite interesting
um
but we have so much content for russian
that link
i think you can find lots at link as
well
and here assalamu alaikum
okay do you know of any place i can find
audio and subtitles in german
uh no you'd have to look i don't know
okay
so joshua here is doing uh master and
margarita and russian he has one on link
and physical book do we learn
differently when it comes to digital
versus paper
uh
i mean
digital is
preferable when it comes to acquiring
vocabulary paper is more comfortable
it's a nicer way to read
what i have done in the past
is
do some of the book in digital because i
acquire new vocabulary and typically a
writer you know one writer will tend to
use some of the same vocabulary over and
over again in a book so you don't have
to do the whole book digitally
you can do some of it there and then
some of it you read you know you're
lying in bed reading your book so you're
able to enjoy it both and i think in
general in in language learning if we're
able to cover the same material
in two or three different ways
that's good so if you can do it
uh you know do your bogakov online and
yet also do it in a book i think that's
reinforcing it's almost a different
experience and so it's reinforced really
reaffirming yeah now what is this here
you know i have to admit that every
script is difficult and it's so small
always i can't read these very well here
good evening thanks
well amanda panda what you need to read
in order to
acquire more links is is dictated by
what you're interested in
so
i can't tell you whether you should read
newspapers or novels
luca says how long characters in
japanese because there are many readings
of every single character
yeah there are many readings of every
single character the biggest issue is
understanding the meaning
to my mind like
recognizing the character
um
but then the the different readings
you're going to gradually get used to
it's almost like a different word
uh through more reading and listening
you'll get more and more comfortable
with the different readings
but you basically have to be able to
identify the character what is the
meaning of this character and that takes
that's difficult for us
yeah use link and ask him at the same
time good idea thanks d great answer
i'll definitely expose myself to both
mediums
okay
that is it
and um
there was this question about importing
so i am now going to try and hook up
again
and
see if i can
okay something i discovered i'd like to
share is using scripts for films
yeah
this is j skills yes and in many cases
if it's a youtube video with subtitles
you can import that into link using our
chrome or browser extension all right
let me just quickly uh see if i can hook
up this here
and i go to
software update is required to cut what
a software update is required to connect
to steve cox would you like to download
the installments update now not now
okay now quicktime player
the operation could not be completed
okay
boy
now i got the whirring beach ball
um
yeah
let's see here
there
try again
quick time player
this time it worked
file new movie recording
it pops up
it's still spinning there hopefully this
is gonna work here we are
okay
it worked
uh now
share screen
that's snap two
start screen share
present everyone
so
now that i've done this
i wonder if i can find where we import
there is a place
import lesson okay
here this is new this is i'm not sure
this exists on the android but it does
exist on the ios version so it's new
sometimes and it may only be on the beta
so i go there i put the title the course
the levels
and i can save it okay
of course i can also
import
if i go
the other way of doing it is if you find
something on the internet
uh
let us see
let's
get out of here
so if i go
to
uh
let's say i'm doing persian persian
online by the way is a great resource
and if i go to intermediate let's see
amir kabir
so i'm not sure this is going to work by
the way
and let's see persian text i know it
works from
uh let's see that's not good we'll get
out of here
let's go
to
um
oh here we are okay so what i do is i go
like this
okay
and then i go to
import link
and it's not arabic
ah it is
or you know since i'm doing arabic today
let's cancel that and let's go to al
jazeera
jazeera.net
okay so we open a lesson here
and i am going to import that i go up
here
and import
as a linked lesson
blah blah blah
save
open
so
and here i have my lesson
and
also reassuring to see that while there
are many blue words there's also many
white words
and yellow words so those are the two
ways of importing
now i am going to get out of here
so stop doing this stop
and uh stop uh sharing this so i yank
this
and i go to
there to find the thing to see if there
was any reaction to that
okay
all right uh
okay
my mom has the same shutters stay from
blue clues
uh a question i learned japanese
composer one more thing
uh
a persian looks interesting
i'm not sure if you missed my question
i'm getting on here very can you give me
any clues on how to learn the
prepositions i didn't say
or with verbs in french
okay
um
you know what you
what i would do is i would save them as
phrases
so you say the first way you can say
and then you'll see a whole bunch of
captured phrases with the
better still when you see a verb
you know uh
whatever it might be you can save like
that's what we're gonna
i'm trying to remember i can't think of
one now but save them together every
time you see a verb with the
verb
[Music]
save that as a phrase maybe even say
three or four words and then tag it as
verb with ah verb with
and then in the vocabulary section you
can get you'll eventually have a hundred
of these and it's that concentrated
exposure and hopefully that makes you
more attentive so that when you're
listening or reading and even reading if
you see
uh verb with the underline it just kind
of try to stimulate the brain to be a
little bit more observant of when it's
do and uh and then when you speak forget
about it and you'll get it wrong and
eventually you'll get it right more
often than wrong and your accuracy will
improve
ah
thank you albert martin you think it's
possible learn three languages at the
same time to fluency no
have you ever watched joe inouye's video
on how the japanese language is the most
difficult language no but i don't
believe it is the most difficult
language japanese is not that difficult
the characters are a problem
but other than that the grammar is not
so complicated
and can you speak arabic not really i'm
trying to learn it
is japanese and chinese
similarly you should learn at the same
time you can learn them both at this
time can you reach b1 chinese informants
yes
okay
and i hope i satisfied then the person
with the question about the prepositions
and the person with the question about
how to import
lessons in the mobile app
okay
that's it
all right thank you for listening bye
for now